hi this is Mario from Mario's math
tutoring in this video we're going to
talk about how to write a triangle
congruence statement sometimes this is
something that students have a lot of
trouble with when they're working with
proving triangles are congruent but what
you want to do is you want to match up
the corresponding sides and the
corresponding angles and you want to
prove the triangles congruent but you
want to write that statement and that's
what we're going to talk about in this
video so we're gonna go through three
examples let's jump into it here with
example a what we're gonna do is we're
gonna try to show that these two
triangles are congruent now you want to
look for the hints so you can see these
arrows here they represent that the
lines are parallel so what I'll
sometimes do is I'll extend you know
these lines a little bit further like so
okay and then I'll extend this
transversal a little bit further like
this and then what you should be able to
see is that you've got two lines cut by
a transversal and we know from the
previous chapter that alternate interior
angles are congruent if the lines are
parallel so in this case we can see that
this angle and this angle are congruent
we also know that this segment DB
is shared between these two triangles so
it's going to be congruent in both
triangles by the reflexive property so
I'm just going to mark that so now we
can prove that these two triangles are
congruent
excuse me using the side angle side so
you can see this angle is in between
these two you know congruent sides to
this triangle you can see the included
angle and these two congruent sides now
here's the key so we're proving the
triangles are congruent by
side-angle-side let's go ahead and write
our triangle congruence statements so
triangle blank is congruent to triangle
blank okay now what I like to do this is
just my little strategy is you see how
there's one mark here this one hash mark
this one - and there's two here and
there's none here so what I'll do is
I'll trace the triangle say C D B back
to C now that goes one to zero
did you see how I did that so when I go
to write this triangle let's see we've
got c d b c d b i went one to zero so
i'm going to do the same pattern I'm
going to go one to zero so I've got a B
d back to a so a BD now another way that
you can take a look at it as you can say
well first and second that C D should be
congruent to first and second that's a B
yep
C D is congruent to a B they both have
one marking or you could say D be that
second and third should match up with BD
okay you can see that's true and then
we've got first and third C B is
congruent to ad so let's see is that
right yep C B matches up with ad that's
another way to do it but I like to trace
it you know and then I can do it that
way too now another way to do it is you
could look at the corresponding angles
that match up see what we're doing is
we're taking this triangle and we're
actually rotating it 180 degrees this
bottom triangle so that the
corresponding parts match up let's go to
the next example so example B we're
trying to prove that these two triangles
are congruent you can see that they
share WY between the two triangles so
I'm just going to put a mark there to
show that there that this is shared
between the two and it's the same in
both triangles so you can see these
triangles are congruent by the angle
side angle
okay angle sine angle so in this
particular case this one was a rotation
this one is actually like a reflection
okay but when I write the triangle
congruence statement triangle blank is
congruent to triangle blank I'm gonna go
like this I'm going to go angle with one
marking side angle with two markings
okay so I'm following this pattern I'm
going W Y Z back to W so W Y Z and then
over for this triangle see I've got the
one marking to back to this thing I'm
going an go side angle and then around
like that so I've got W Y X okay that's
one way to approach it another way to
approach is just see okay how everything
matches up so if I fold this I can see W
matches with itself W Y matches with
itself Y so you can see W Y W Y and then
Z is matching with X okay third and last
example here we've got two triangles and
you can see if this is a right angle
this must also be a right angle because
they form a linear pair or a straight
line we can see that the hypotenuse is
are congruent that's the side that's
across from the right angle and we also
know that this angle and this angle are
congruent
because it's marked as such so what we
have here is we have angle angle side
angle angle side so these triangles are
congruent by the angle angle side and we
know the triangle congruence state
that's going to look something like this
but we want to make sure we match up the
corresponding sides and the
corresponding angles so here let's do it
this way let's do triangle B e a now
there's more than one way to write these
okay you just want to make sure that
they're the corresponding parts match up
so B ei so I went from the right angle
to this angle to no markings right so I
want to do the same thing right angle
one marking - no marking so that's going
to be BCD and now I know that the
corresponding parts are matching up now
once you have the triangle congruence
statement you could write it in any
number of ways like I could say let me
do it this way AE B C is going to be
congruent to DC B right that's another
way to write it or you could write it as
how else you can say you know e a B so
I'm doing second third first CD B second
third first you just want to make sure
that the corresponding parts match up so
whichever method that I demonstrate it
you know works best for you
stick with that method until you know
you can switch easily between the
different techniques so I hope this
helped you to understand how to work
with the writing trial congruence
statements better subscribe to the
channel I check out more math tutoring
videos on Mario's math tutor and YouTube
channel and I look forward to seeing in
the future videos I'll talk to you soon